this is a production of cornell
university
yeah thanks everyone for joining uh this
is week five episode 10 of the cornell
turf show this year
we're gonna have a lawn and landscape
episode today with dr doug soldat
university wisconsin madison
uh you loyal listeners and watchers will
know doug from past seasons
we're going to talk about
common lawn issues soil physical
properties today will come up
who knows where we'll go from there but
certainly a common issue we see and one
that's maybe difficult to address for
for homeowners and landscape contractors
so
excited for that conversation uh but as
always frank i'll let you start us off
maybe with uh you've always got an
interesting image a fun image to show us
and of course weather weather updates as
well that's a big part of this
there we go
you got the slides carl
perfect all right good
welcome to the program thanks uh doug
for joining us thank you all our
our uh
our our loyal our loyal live listeners
and for those of you listening on the
podcast and and watching the webinar
later uh welcome it's we're gonna be
talking soils today but i thought i'd
start out with a really cool picture um
of a lawn in arkansas
that is in bloom it looks like a tall
fescue lawn that's got these beautiful
hyacinths in them
and really important for pollinators uh
the conversation is continuing to grow
about this kind of alternative to lawn
stuff in the spring
thank you can you share your your uh
slides we're still looking at uh
okay you're not looking at the slides
yeah try try again
let's try again here we go
thank you
perfect there we go got me carl yeah now
you're looking at the hyacinth lawn
yep excellent sorry about that so there
we are
lawn alternatives
but this was the slide for today
i pulled this uh off of um
a newspaper article that was writing
about this issue
and um
you know
these are the kinds of hourly wages
that this industry is confronting in
heavily urbanized heavily urbanized
heavily landscaped areas
um and that's probably an issue that's
dominating a lot of the conversation
uh in this industry right now not just
in lawn and grounds i just happen to be
landscape help but the golf industries
uh sports industries are facing the same
situation so carl let's do some numbers
about lawns and home value for why this
is so important to have people to uh
come and and labor over it
yeah so so we've talked about ecosystem
services and and what grass and lawns
can provide from a
carbon sequestration storm water runoff
uh perspective but there is some value
in just it looking good in in your lawn
and at your household and and this was a
study where they looked at a bunch of
housing listings in a certain area i
believe it was tennessee
and they essentially rated the landscape
quality was it below average average
good excellent
and they normalized all these housing
values for that landscape quality
and they found if you can make your
landscape go from average looking to
good looking you'll increase your home
value by almost six percent
and furthermore if you increase it from
an average quality
landscape to an excellent landscape
you'll increase your home value by 11
and and essentially what they found is
for every dollar you invest
in your landscape and this is not turf
grass specific it's a it's about mulch
beds and trees as well
but for every dollar you invest in your
landscape you're going to get a dollar
35 in housing value so a really
interesting way to think about hey
what's the value of things looking good
at your home hey carl can i interrupt
quick yeah this stuff is cool but
did you i wonder how they controlled for
like the stuff on the inside of the
house because i'm thinking about people
that have a nice landscape they usually
take care good care of the inside of the
house so they do they talk about that at
all somebody's got a really bad
landscape i know that they're probably
inside the house is bad too and that
yeah factor that in the house yeah i
think they looked at the age of the
house as a control um
and then i think they bracketed by uh
uh cost ranges so you know 200 to 250
000. i think they were sort of assuming
um if it was about the same value they
do square footage i think was another
control variable it's not perfect
um but it was interesting and this is
this was also this landscape quality
metric was actually pretty heavily
influenced by trees and
i think they actually found like sixty
percent if sixty percent of the
home of the um lot area was covered by
trees that was the ideal shade
percentage they even mentioned that in
there which is interesting so if you're
over shaded or undershaded that affected
value um so yeah some really interesting
stuff is it
uh is that a hard and fast number
no and and it was one region so you know
who knows how that
translates to places up up north but um
it's it's interesting nonetheless to see
that general value of
hey things look better you you get
better home value i mean talk about this
same thing with uh like fixing a kitchen
or fixing a bathroom or fixing a bedroom
yeah right inside for every dollar you
invest in it
you'd like to think you're getting
something out
um so i would look at those you're i
think you're right about that doug you
got to be careful what you control for
here but i think there is this cultural
norm
that this represents in some cases that
that where people would look at certain
traditional landscapes
uh and view them as kempt kept and like
hoas
have guidelines for these things right i
think a lot of that thinking is based in
the cultural norms of the picture in the
background here but yeah trying to
correct for some of the other variables
is tricky but i i think this informs a
lot of stuff uh
about even you know what we're forced to
manage so listen i gotta this is great
we got a lot of curveballs ahead of us
together today actually poached some of
your slides that i'm going to ask you
about too so we're going to have lots of
fun doing this so let's get with the
weather and overall it was you know two
to four degrees above normal last week
so a little bit warmer than normal
we're expecting the six to ten day
outlook by the prediction
models that we typically look at
uh each time we hold this uh session are
looking clearly below normal like it's
going to be cold again so you know the
the roller coaster ride uh that we're on
looks like it's heading down now into
low temperatures
and how that manifests itself as the
growing season doesn't progress and one
of the metrics of watching the growing
season progress is how many days is it
different from normal and how many
growing degree days base 50 do we expect
to accumulate right this is a good
measure of how much does a growing
season compare to normal and how is it
going to be progressing moving forward
and so one of the things we're seeing is
that we're right around normal through
most of the northeastern regions uh
maybe even a little bit ahead along the
coastline as you get inland and higher
elevations a little bit further behind
normal and then the forecast moving
forward is a lot more than it's been
right we've typically been looking at
you know single digit and maybe low teen
accumulation and you can see we're
starting to get into the 20 to 30
growing degree day accumulation over a
five day period so we're going to see
some progression of the potential for
the turf to grow
this using just using a metric for the
potential that the system may have to go
um obviously between 50 and 58 degrees
you see a
pretty quick increase
in the potential for the turf to grow
now this is not an ideal or complete
measurement of how the grass will grow
but it's an indication
of the kind of growth you might expect
based on the average temperature likely
to increase over the next several weeks
now we tend to use phenological
indicators in this process and so we're
starting to hear about a little bit of
green showing up on the forsythia in the
metropolitan new york area and you look
at the gdd tracker one of the tools in
lawn and grounds we use uh the
phenological indicators four is for
crabgrass germination so i like to use
another
data tool in addition to the
phenological indicator in addition to
potential growing degree days but
looking at the growing degree day
tracker and seeing where crabgrass might
be germinating based on this model set
for
the metropolitan new york area you can
see even into southern jersey we're
still a little bit ahead
we might start seeing it in the next
couple of weeks but this is an
indication that you still have a little
bit of time to get some seed down if
you're using pre-emergent herbicide to
get that pre-emergent herbicide down
because you're still a little bit ahead
of germination
the other aspect of weed control we talk
about again not ideal we'd rather you
did broadleaf weed control in the fall
particularly perennial broad leaflet
control but if you're going you got a
new customer or dandelions are starting
to pop uh the ester and amine
formulations we have some models that we
verified from the old purdue research uh
that basically says yeah you're starting
to get into favorable way down in the
southern tip of new jersey in the
atlantic city area
two in soils temperatures are are uh
revealing
how warm it was last week and how much
the system accelerated if you remember
we were at 48 degrees
at peak uh two in soil temperature last
week and the models are saying we're
well into the mid to upper 50s now
throughout the metropolitan new york
area
now rainfall wise if you were in the
hudson valley northern jersey
orange county uh maybe a little bit
along the connecticut massachusetts
vermont new york borders uh you got
maybe an inch uh two to three inches but
if you were in the middle of that vein
maybe poughkeepsie
maybe it looks
like i'm trying to figure out where that
is yeah that's that looks not far from
poughkeepsie you might have been four
inches of rain so that's a real big dump
so looking at that uh
rainfall
now that we're starting to warm up
evapotranspiration is getting a little
bit better right we're getting a little
higher levels of evapotranspiration
we're starting to see things dry out a
little bit so the yield from a rain
event is going to start to be reduced
right because you're going to lose a
little bit if it comes down really fast
like that four inch rain it's more
likely to run off than necessarily get
absorbed okay depending on the rate at
which that fell
so paying attention now to
evapotranspiration it's early days but i
can tell you in the gulf side where
they've got injured annual bluegrass
they're starting to put some water on it
because they're noticing those
compromised plants and sand-based soils
are a little bit uh
they do better with a little bit of
water up at the surface
hard to call rainfall what it's going to
be looks like there might be a couple of
systems moving through
as you get north it might be more above
normal we're expecting normal precip
might be a little bit drier to the south
all right
so
i want to start the soil conversation by
saying how often times
weed populations are related to poor
soil conditions
how sometimes good lawns in the spring
may have nothing to do with how you
fertilize but has a lot to do with the
condition of the soil in particular as
oftentimes we have dog we tend to talk
about physical properties of the soil
doug's seen this picture i've used it in
the past when he was on the show here
are the kinds of problematic situations
you get in urban environments where
you've got a focused traffic area soils
prone to compaction you know what makes
them good to grow in
uh sometimes can make them more prone to
compaction and so we start to think
about how do we move water through these
compacted situations
and we go back to the old 50s movie of
the core
uh filled with straw
water dripping and the wetting front of
the soil as it's impacted by that
macropore that the air vacation creates
so doug some of the discussion today
we've had it before but i'm pulling in
some urban environmental stuff i've seen
you talk about
is that first off that particularly when
we talk about lawn and grounds native
soils it's important to remind folks
that sometimes the benefits of these uh
errification events are fairly
short-lived
and so you combine that i pulled this
off of one of the common uh sort of
youtube lawn stars out there that was
promoting the need to air file a lawn
that already looks this freaking good
right and and is using the trap the
traditional um drum air fire
and doug i've poached a couple of slides
from some of your talks so this these
should be familiar to you um looking at
the spacing here on some of these drum
rollers
can be as much as five six inches
and so i
you know this common slide that's used
that you use that the usga has about
how big is the time you're poking in the
ground
how far apart are they
how much of the actual surface area you
impact
and then of course this was about how
much sand you could incorporate right
because it typically is associated with
a um herified sand putty green you can
see really clearly and for those uh
watch or listening on the podcast i'm
circling the largest tine at 5 8 inches
i'm sorry 5 8 of an inch
and one inch by one inch spacings
affects about 30 percent uh of the
surface of the turf area and so looking
back we are no we're
a fifth you know we're much less than
that at a five inch spacing
so
we have
limited amount of area that we impact
generally um we have the potential when
we don't time verification right doug as
you've shown in these slides can then
create uh some challenge around weed
seed germination drought stress winter
desiccation
and you've talked about
ameliorating that's a great word you
must have learned that when you were
here and me and you and michael were
talking about you know
lugubrious and fancy words like that uh
how you fix these problems in urban
soils through the addition of compost
and then i grabbed some of your blast
from the past here it's like okay the
move with a bad soil
is to verify it and put compost so i'm
setting you up here now you can see on
the buffalo site and the rochester site
compared to control
the infiltration uh generally increased
uh as you put different types of manure
now i know you've changed some of this
work in working with yard waste
but in this slide deck i got my hands on
you had these great pictures
of the impact of particularly phosphorus
which is the nutrient of concern as you
indicated in these um
in these slides the nutrient of concern
in urban areas that leads to that
eutrophication
right nitrogen is the issue maybe more
so in an agricultural situation but in
urban areas a pretty good indication in
this particular slide how phosphorus uh
potentially is causing the trouble
now you
again i want to see where you gave this
talk that i poached those things from uh
because this was really fascinating you
brought in some of our colleagues zach
easton's work when he was studying here
but essentially when you look at urban
runoff and i know carl appreciate this
we're talking about this all the time
these days
as you get the places where you get more
grass you get a significant reduction in
runoff
so doug in this in this presentation you
talked a little bit about this watershed
project in connecticut that i want to
set you up for here
and basically start out with this simple
question
does routine aeration and compost
addition
improve soil health
and reduce environmental risk does the
way
we want to fix these poor soils in urban
conditions
uh reduce environmental risk
and fix the soil
so
how's that first set up that's great
that's great thank you so where do you
want to start um you want to start with
this question yeah yeah we can for sure
the other thing i'll get you thinking
about too i've been hearing a lot about
nomo may i don't know if you guys have
covered that but um don't worry let's
talk about that
all right we're still in recreational
mowing in some places here in
the northeast okay okay so um
yeah yeah yeah so okay so i agree with
with uh kind of what you said up there
with that picture the ruler and
verification sounds like great it's one
of those things that sounds a lot better
than it is
um but the reality is especially with
the home lawn equipment you're just not
you're just not poking enough holes to
really affect the soil physical
properties
but there's something to be said for
just being out there and doing it right
we talk about that in the gulf you got
ice on the greens i don't know we don't
know what the solution is but if you go
out there and do something it looks like
you tried
um so that's kind of that's what i'll
say about verification it's a way to
increase revenue
form some goodwill with your customers
it makes sense to them
but but you want to be prepared for the
fact that their blonde probably isn't
going to improve that much if it's truly
compacted so for those the the you know
the picture of the person you showed
with like the best lawn in the
neighborhood doing it
okay yeah
that's that's fine
the logic is this doug
let's steal the logic from god well it
wouldn't look that good if i didn't do
it i'd do this that's right twice a year
and that's why it looks this good as
soon as i don't do it oh
it's gonna fall apart yeah
um but the thing that really works is
the top dressing the compost you know we
did that study they showed um rochester
and buffalo and we were down in
minnesync and
white plains uh
the
we did it in wisconsin here too it works
the problem with it is it's a ton of
labor you've got to find a good source
of compost and spread it out on top and
kind of the recommendation that we've
settled on now is about a quarter inch
in the spring and a quarter inch of the
fall now the the products we were using
in the new york study were composted
manures
which are loaded with phosphorus so you
know that's one of the problems is
we want to reduce phosphorus in in turf
soils and urban environments so those
are not going to be ways to do that well
what we've been finding in wisconsin is
they've used the composted yard waste
they're much much lower in nutrients and
they provide
the same or even better
physical
benefits
do you need property
or i think i've heard you say you're
just better off just spreading them do
you need to fight that's right so in the
in the new york study we did we had
verification
with and without compost it didn't
matter so um the verification is not
what's improving things it's the compost
so just top dress the compost on if
you're really trying to um be the most
efficient
um
so yeah after a couple two three years
of that you'll that's all you need it's
not like you have to continually do it
but two three years of a quarter inch
will build up that that surface to the
point where you can grow pretty healthy
grass so now this study that i ended the
study in wisconsin
in
2016. okay six years ago i don't have
the plots marked out
but just last week i walked out and i
can point to the plots that had the
compost on them six years ago they're
that much better so i mean that's it
three years of quarter inch spring fall
and you you basically fixed that soil or
improved it okay so so listen
so here's the angle i'm getting at here
the angle is okay
it's one thing you know
the question is do you need to do it on
those lawns that already look really
good and don't have an infiltration or
soil physical problem and i'm hearing
you say well it looks like you're doing
something but you're not getting a lot
of benefit
if you do have restricted infiltration
compacted soils maybe in some areas on a
campus in grounds large grounds
maintenance areas where people are doing
things
you can improve the infiltration there
do you think that there's an argument to
be made when you do have compacted soils
that this has an environmental benefit i
know horgan might have looked at this
once before the role of verification and
fixing that soil and improving
infiltration
and improving the water quality in the
urban environment even you know even if
you're fertilizing that lawn yeah so how
does soil management relate to improved
environmental quality assuming we're not
using the phosphorus loaded stuff yeah
yeah no it's it's the most important
thing so the the ability of the soil to
absorb water is the most important
ecosystem service that we're providing
and so your job if your job is
as a turf manager is to do that in an
urban environment that that's what you
need to do is how do we get more water
into the soil and so you might have to
renovate it
you might have to put in like a
artificial
sand compost mix to help soak in water
you might be able to do it by top
dressing compost but that's what you got
to do
because that's where that's where the
environmental impact is if you get the
water from the streets and the driveways
on the rooftops and
the soil can't accept it then it ends up
in the streams and the lakes and even if
there's no
not carrying phosphorus from the
fertilizer it's carrying phosphorus from
the sediment in the streets and the tree
leaves that are breaking down so you
just got to stop the flow of water you
want the soils to accept the water and
that's tough and that's why we have so
many drainage problems right because the
turf is already doing that
and then we're putting more water on it
from the high school parking lot or
whatever
and then soils are compacted from gym
class so
it really is something that has to be
actively actively managed and but
understanding that what frank just said
there that the the ability of soil
absorb water is the number one
environmental benefit that your turf
area can provide you that's the way you
want to think about it
that's what i'm trying to get at and i'm
also trying to realize how much does the
way we design these urban environments
impact the benefits or they can have and
that brings up the jordan cove
experiment
uh can you talk a little bit about
bmps for urban landscape design a little
bit that then make it easier for us to
not spill stuff on the pavement uh all
the time
yeah that i think that jordan cove it's
an older project it's been done for a
while i think the website's still up and
they and they do a really nice job you
can take a tour of all the bmps they
used and if you look at them you know
the way i contextualize that one is like
look we know how to solve the
environmental problems that we have
that's not the issue and that jordan
cove
projects proves it to a point like you
could they actually improved the
environment over doing nothing in some
cases by just engineering the
environment to accept water
and so it's things like uh sharing a
driveway you know there's two just
reducing impervious area uh the
impervious area they have make it
pervious use porous concrete use porous
pavers
um green gardens rain gardens just filth
it's all about the water management we
know how to do it why doesn't it happen
because of money so it's an economic
thing the houses that they built in that
jordan cove project that were bmps uh
cost fifty to a hundred thousand dollars
more and you know that's money money
rules everything right so people aren't
doing it the regulations aren't there
because if you make the regulations they
increase the cost of construction can be
super unpopular and votes you out
so um
yeah that's the sad realities we know
how to do this stuff it's just it takes
it takes money and you're probably
thinking if you're you know
yeah i got compacted runoff so i can't i
don't have the budget to fix them like i
can't replace the soils so so so the
other thing i want to throw in before we
take any questions or carl if you got a
comment
um
what about that guy with the nice long
what about the cost of showing your
customers you're doing something and
building your revenue like that or
thinking you know doing verification in
areas that's not needed number one
you're burning fossil fuels to do it
number two
how much soil gas goes off is this
completely crazy doug is the same rule
applied because we're not affecting much
of the soil we probably don't
burp off a lot of soil gases
what is your sense of that crazy
idea of ecosystem disservice
yeah that's good i think let's start
with the last one if you poke a hole and
you pull a core some of that carbon some
of that organic matter is going to gas
off but my my guess is
that you poke the hole it's going to
fill back with roots and it's probably
net zero so i don't see a big problem
with that i but you're right on the fuel
use absolutely so that's one thing that
the turf industry michael my student
michael beckham wrote a nice paper about
this for the international turf grass
conference
that shows that you know
when you you convert a corn field or to
grass you start sequestering carbon
into the soil but it you only get about
20 30 years until you become
uh
zero right and then all the fuel you're
using to maintain it is a carbon cost so
you know as turf managers we got to
start thinking about how do we reduce
our energy use in maintaining these
landscapes and i think we're seeing that
with battery-powered stuff that we can
charge with renewable energy but
certainly yeah if you're
over managing stuff that you're just
wasting fuel if you don't need to do it
perfect
carl what do you think
yeah the thing i'll add doug and this is
actually going to be our tip of the day
next week is is the cost or the
the energy consumption shipping
materials
top dressing to a golf course getting
equipment made into a golf course i
think michael showed that has the
highest energy consumption greenhouse
gas consumption of compared to energy
use on property so that's another thing
uh when we're doing things i think you
call it recreationally frank
recreational mowing there's a cost to
that as well there are a couple
questions um
uh rich bradley's got a question on
sandy soils raising cec values um any
kind of
compost specific compost leaf compost
uh suggestions there to raise so using
using soil amendments doug to improve
chemical properties of the soil right
yeah
yeah uh
organic matter will do it the just the
way organ the nature of chemical nature
of organic matter it's got a lot of
those negative charges so zeolites the
pro you know the inorganic amendments
probably not worth the cost just go with
any organic matter and that's going to
increase that exchange capacity and the
water holding capacity watch your
phosphorous levels right doug you're
part of your rule with organic matter
is
you're not putting a quarter inch of
dairy manure biosolid on lawns
comfortably you're saying if you're
going to use it it's got to be a
particular kind of compost and let me
bug you on this does the
is it consistent
is you're playing around with yard waste
or you're poking around when you talk
about people about this do you hear
comments about consistency msw to ms you
know municipal waste to municipal waste
yeah and that's a big issue all those
sources are going to be different and um
the big suppliers of it are usually
pretty good they're testing it
frequently they got records so
um i and i would say i probably have
less issues with the yard waste stuff
because there's less like potential for
urine and salts like that but penn
state's got a great compost
testing lab i'm sure there's others out
there but i send my compost when i'm
doing research out to penn state and
they'll tell you if everything's in spec
but you want to make sure that those
things are in spec yard waste is going
to have lower nutrients which is going
to be beneficial for urban environments
right
what's the other question we're not
going to let you go doug you wanted to
talk about nomo may and i sense a maybe
a controversial opinion on that we've
been talking out about bulbs in the lawn
frankie showed that the picture of the
hyacinths people letting that grow as
as long grass native grass until maybe
june uh what are your thoughts on on
nomo may i mean i i love that people are
thinking about uh law and ecology that's
really cool i just feel like it's like
everything else you get come up with a
cool tag line and you think you solve
the problem but i mean
my thought if if mowing was removing all
the dandelion heads and all the
flowering clover and
creeping charlie we wouldn't be trying
to control them i mean that those things
bloom underneath the canopy in most
cases so like talking about recreational
mowing we'll play on words here the
tagline should be mow high
may june and july right or something
like that
where
where those you're allowing those what
we traditionally call weeds to bloom
and they're pollinators and you're
mowing above it and so when a dandelion
then after the yellow flower comes up
the white puffball goes way above and
you can mow that off but i i don't think
that bowing is going to increase
pollination at all i think it's do you
kill your weeds or not you know don't
kill your clover also what hap what
blooms in may great we're feeding we're
feeding pollinators just in may that
doesn't make any sense we got to focus
on the clover which blooms june july
august september um you know i think i
again i love that people are talking
about it but i feel like the message of
like let's just not mow in may and
that's gonna solve the problems it's
pretty pretty ridiculous and creating
it's gonna create headaches for
municipalities and schools that have to
come in and deal with it so you're gonna
need bush hawks yeah yeah
exactly and it's gonna scalp the turf
it's gonna create all kinds of problems
i think just mow high most sharp blades
three four inches don't kill your weeds
you know don't call them weeds anymore
call them you know lawn pollinator
plants
and we're going to be in a better better
position i got to tell you that the
thing is doug as this you're exactly
right about the no mo may it's good
people are thinking about it but the
concept that relaxed mowing
could potentially allow
more flowering
plants to thrive in lawn settings
is going to take time because what
you're saying is i think what's going to
happen the minute you stop mowing the
first thing you're going to seal those
lawn weeds that we've selected for for
the last 50 years for the way we've
managed our lawns
and if you want a more diverse lawn
planting
and you want to relax your mowing
strategically two things well don't do
it when the grass grows the most
like in
no november you see some guys like me
who can barely get a beard and then i
got a buddy who's like
you know flavor saver eating food out of
his beard after a month so i do think
it's important to understand that things
this is a bad time to do it but as we
think more about servicing pollinators
what your point is what we'll end with
carl here
carl
doug's point about this that pollinators
want to be there as long as they're
there the minute they get here or start
doing their thing they want to be here
for the length of your growing season
right and if all you do is help them in
may i don't see what good i'm with you
on that i don't see what good that
entirely does
using the lawn has a habitat
thanks doug good to see you good to see
you thanks for having the weeks looking
forward to getting back to mad down
absolutely
thanks everybody
yeah thanks everyone uh this is uh
episode 10 in the books thanks to doug
um we'll post a bunch of these links
that you heard about today just posted a
nice link about uh b lawns from the
university of minnesota so check those
out in the video below we'll see you
next week
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu